RYAN MATSUMOTO: Cloud Bigtable
is Google Cloud's NoSQL
database designed to
handle large analytical and
operational workloads.
It's used by many companies
across a diverse array
of industries, including
fintech, adtech, gaming, IoT,
and more.
So how do you know if Cloud
Bigtable is right for you?
Today, we're highlighting
three industries
that rely on Bigtable to
solve challenges, reduce
costs, and accelerate innovation
to deliver a great experience
for customers.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In our last episode, we covered
why Bigtable is a great option
to hit the optimal balance
between speed, scalability,
and reliability
for your database.
In this episode, we're
going to connect the dots
to show you how Bigtable can
be used to solve problems
in areas like retail,
transportation, and fraud
detection.
First up, retail.
Say you're a major retailer
that manages hundreds of stores
and millions of products.
Bigtable's scalability
can help you
handle the massive amount of
data that needs to be stored.
You can store data in Bigtable's
NoSQL key-value format.
Each row might represent
an individual item
at a specific store,
with the key being
a combination of the
item ID and location,
and columns being
the price and the ID
of the person who updated it.
It's also important
to be able to support
a large number of
reads per second,
since you'll likely have
many concurrent requests
from tens of thousands
of registers,
as well as from
the online store.
Bigtable has you
covered with the ability
to support millions of
requests per second.
And finally, low
latency is a must-have.
You wouldn't want
customers to have
to wait a while for employees to
retrieve prices during a sale.
This isn't a problem
with Bigtable,
though, since it has
latency on the order
of single-digit milliseconds.
Next, we have transportation.
Imagine you're a public-sector
employee working on a dashboard
to display real-time information
about a city bus system.
This use case requires you to
have a database like Bigtable
that can handle a massive
amount of throughput,
since you'll want to store and
retrieve data for thousands
of buses minute by minute.
Bigtable's low latency
is also important,
since riders need to get
accurate bus information
as quickly as possible.
Bigtable's data model
also makes it easy
for you to store time series
data about bus locations.
Your data set might
include a row for each bus,
with trip ID as the
row key, and columns
for origin ID, destination
ID, latitude, and longitude.
At the intersection of each
row and column combination,
you can have multiple cells,
with each cell representing
a different version of the
data at a given timestamp.
In this example, you can
easily store timestamp values
for latitude and longitude at
different times of the day.
Another use case for
Bigtable is fraud detection.
Fraud detection
companies need to be
able to quickly and reliably
tell clients whether or not
they should charge
a credit card.
When a transaction comes
in, you can quickly
pull the customer profile
from Bigtable with low latency
and make that decision.
Scale is another
important consideration.
Maybe you have a major client
with thousands of stores,
billions of dollars
of revenue per year,
and millions of
transactions per day.
Thanks to Bigtable's
scalability,
you can store up to petabytes
of data in the cloud
and keep up with all
the requests that
now come in from this client.
And since Bigtable is a
fully managed service,
you can seamlessly scale up
and down with zero downtime.
And finally, machine learning
can help improve the fraud
detection process.
Data can be inputted into an
ML model to get a prediction,
but can also be used
to further train the ML
model for future predictions.
For this ML pipeline
to work, data
needs to be read and
written to the database
continuously for millions
of requests per day,
making Bigtable a great option
because of its high throughput.
So there you have it, a dip
into the benefits of Bigtable's
speed, scalability,
and reliability
in retail, transportation,
and fraud detection.
Bigtable's speed means that it
can support millions of reads
and writes per second
at low latency.
Scalability means that you can
quickly scale up your database
by adding Bigtable nodes that
add 10,000 additional requests
per second at no downtime.
And reliability means that
Bigtable adds up to 99.999%
availability SLA.
This video is just a sampling
of the many industries and use
cases where Bigtable helps
companies solve problems
and grow their businesses.
So if you're curious
to learn more,
follow the links below
for more information.
Thanks for joining
us today, and stay
tuned for more episodes
about Bigtable.